hello mug club and all you strange
animals I had the privilege of sitting
down with Alex Jones to discuss the end
times are we living in the end times
that are spoken about in the Bible what
pieces are in place that make the end
times even possible whether it be Israel
being in the land in 1948 the invention
of satellite television for the whole
world to watch the two witnesses being
murdered or maybe the precursor to the
mark of the beast with chips being
implanted right now into people's bodies
you have got to hear what Alex Jones has
to say about this topic it is absolutely
fascinating and look all of this is only
possible because of you mug Club
remember your support provides all of
the opportunity for us to do this and in
fact our show in general which comes
back August 14th remember bookmark it
next Monday August 14th we are back
Monday through Friday 10 a.m eastern
time make sure you are there
listen without your support none of this
is possible but hold on to your butts
Alex Jones end times prophecy it is
going to be interesting
[Music]
guys is apologetics it doesn't mean that
all right mug Club hey everybody thank
you for joining us for Gerald apologizes
apologetics it doesn't quite mean what
they say that it means I understand that
they just do that to kind of uh I don't
know Punk me because we spend all this
money on the intros for everybody else
but not for me that's fine that's fine
I'll get over it I'll be okay don't
worry about me I I had an interesting
conversation back in June with our guest
today and it it was very quick on the
show and we started talking about demons
in the mark of the beast and I was like
how that that's that's eschatology I'm
very interested in that and so Alex
Jones I thought I'd come down here and
hang out in your world and we could
continue our conversation I think it
literally lasted maybe 60 seconds on air
and we didn't really get into it a whole
lot Captain Morgan you are now promoted
to Admiral Morgan Admiral Morgan sitting
in this chair is a little weird I mean
it's like huh this is it's kind of a
nice place I like it I've seen this on
on the air I love you in Steven's studio
and you got to get Stephen back down
here sometime I know one of these days
we're gonna get him in the car or maybe
we've done shows on the street together
but never in the studio I remember that
you said something about Bumpass I
believe being
I actually did throw up it was so gross
so is it just the smell of that yeah
just the smell of it or the thought and
I was extremely hungover that day too so
let's not lie no no I mean I'm a lay
person when it comes to into the world
type stuff but I did go to a lot of
church a lot of Sunday school I have
read the Bible quite a bit I know
there's massive amounts of study I mean
you could have five degrees and never
know half of it but my grandfather
my mother's father was really heavily
into it studied the Bible Daniel and
Ezekiel and and
Revelation pretty much like five hours a
day he was really smart and and a quite
a historian he'd been a successful
inventor right a lot of other things but
uh last 20 years of his life he was
dedicated studying the Bible I remember
him like breaking down the New World
Order and Global government they'd have
a computer and they would control
everybody and you'd have to do what they
said or you wouldn't get the mark you
would always explain you don't just take
it and then it's because you've taken it
that you're gonna go to hell it's that
taking it you have to submit and worship
and follow the whole system so he would
basically rant kind of like Alex Jones
almost like he was my grandfather he
would look like me uh just about this
all the time and I would come and visit
him in the Summers and then and then I'm
I moved down here when I was a senior in
high school started hanging out with him
and my grandmother almost every week
what years roughly what decade was this
uh I was graduated out of high school in
92. okay and so I moved here like in
1991.
and so my grandparents lived here yeah
and he was just really big into
eschatology and so that that I mean I
heard a lot from him well the church
used to be really big into it and that's
why I was really asking that because
back in the 1980s I mean there was a lot
of fire in Brimstone preaching and a
part of that was telling the end of the
story so let me just tell the the guys
listening and gals right now we're
talking about the end time so
eschatology is kind of the study of the
end times and just so you understand
what that is if Genesis is kind of
telling the beginning of the story which
it obviously is uh Revelation and some
of the prophetic literature leading up
to that is really telling you how things
come to an end and some of the things
that Alex just said would have just been
in the 1960s 1950s 40s 1800s you're
crazy there's no way any of that stuff
could happen but obviously we see a lot
of it happening today and so people are
very interested it's apocalyptic anytime
you see a History Channel show that
talks about the apocalypse or something
like that people tune in because they're
like oh there's something that draws Us
in to want to know a little bit more and
this subject is debated quite a bit
right we were talking just a second ago
about mid-trib pre-trib post trip no
trip whatever there are a lot of
different reasons for you to care about
this right we'll dive into just a very
basic framework of what we're talking
about and then we're going to talk about
specific segments specifically 666 the
mark of the beast how that's being
potentially implemented today and how uh
how you can make sure that you don't
accidentally do that you can't that's
the whole the kind of the trick to it
you can't accidentally take the mark of
the beast but we're going to hit a few
more points maybe something that most
people don't know is that for every
prophecy on the first coming of Christ
which that is the Messiah that is for
the Jews that's it right they were
waiting for and looking for and
desperately hoping for messiah to come
for every Prophecy in the Bible about
messiah's first coming they're roughly
eight concerning the second coming
there's eight more than the first coming
right so it's multiple times more
mentioned in the Bible and a lot of
people don't really take a lot of time
to understand those prophecies or to
really kind of think through it they do
take time to go Revelation is tough to
understand Revelation is difficult
because there's there's is all this
imagery that's being used and there's
all this flowery language that I don't
really understand and we'll get into why
some Christians have a bit of a problem
with that but it's important for you to
know because God spent about eight times
the time speaking about the second
coming then he did the first coming and
obviously the first one was a big deal
because it kind of Saved people without
the first coming the second coming
doesn't really quite matter that much
because we would all be under judgment
and I wouldn't want to be around for
that anyway but I guess my big question
Alex is why what made you start so you
talked about it a little bit was your
grandfather you said yes so other than
that was there any influence or was it
just your grandfather's influence
talking about kind of eschatology that
made you dive into it a little bit well
I want to be 100 clear
I mean the New World Order has brought
us the end times and has proven the
Bible's rights so that's why I'm way
more interested I mean growing up we
went to church on Sundays and then we
would have Bible studies a lot of times
at the house at Sunday night when my
parents LED uh and and I could watch if
I wanted to and hang out there if I
wanted to and that's going to be like 20
people there but usually there'd be some
other kids we run around outside uh and
we went to you know Church on Wednesdays
and we went to a Evangelical style you
know a pretty big church and and so I
was just growing up with this as a
background and so it's kind of the back
of your head yeah and then my
grandfather uh once I moved to Austin
when I was college and then you have my
job and already on air for a lot of
years
he died about 12 years ago my
grandmother about five years ago he was
just constantly saying watch this is all
going to be fulfilled and he would get
really upset when he'd see these
preachers on TV setting a date he would
say those people are deceived by setting
a date then when it doesn't happen
that's gonna make people fall away
that's a tool the devil right and he was
just really uh he said you know comes
like a thief in the night no man Noah
it's Christ of the hour of the return
and so then I've seen the left use that
when these preachers get a bunch of
attention saying it's this date for like
a year then it doesn't happen
then they say oh the Bible's disproven
now the Bible says no one knows and if
they tell you they know that person's
bad yeah exactly so it's all there and
so the older you get the more you know
you go this is incredible like that I
get chills right now so I want to be
clear I'm not Mr preacher and I'm not
holier than thou uh I mean I don't tell
lies on purpose and I don't sell out to
evil but I mean I made the point about
being hungover that's probably why I was
throwing up I mean I've got my own
issues I'm not perfect I'll do I'm not
on some high horses so many people are
turned off by the church
because it's it's it's it's preaching
watered-down uh Bible and it's it it's
also just attacking people individually
instead of showing them the big picture
the devil's real God's real you better
pick a side and so people ask well I'm
so much in the end times is
it's here and it's all being fulfilled
and the globalists are fulfilling it and
saying the future's not human you will
merge the machines you will submit to
all our social credit scores our esg's
you'll be tracked in live time uh the
Bible says everyone worldwide will see
the image of the Beast talking to them
at once they'll worship it and that's
television Holograms right I mean it's
it's like there's no way Johnny Ola
Patmos two thousand years ago just made
this up there's no way Daniel just made
it up or Ezekiel and it's just all
congruent proving itself proving and
self-proving itself and so if someone
doesn't have the holy spirit of
discernment they read it's much
gibberish but once you actually are plus
we're living in the time you said
something so important I'll shut up for
a minute Gerald and that is
in in the in the 70s and 80s I mean
there I was not just going to our church
but I would also go with my friends to
their church and it was like like there
were all these movies and films and
people were really awake there's going
to be a one world government the Beast
system in Brussels and a beast computer
everywhere it was everywhere and then
once the 90s and the 2000s and once it
all started coming true the preachers
went whoa because it's one thing to say
the Bible says it's coming and then it's
kind of like science fiction and really
interesting but now a lot of the
preachers are like whoa I'm not going to
scare the hell out of people which is
actually we should be celebrating and
going my gosh our God is real right this
is a warning God gave us free will but
God also gave us a cheat sheet yeah and
and so like hey kids I want you to pass
the test here kind of here's the so if
you pay attention you will so this is a
big deal and this is 100 real and then I
think about the experience sizes I had
in Dallas particularly and then coming
to Austin and then being around
Hollywood which never tried to be in but
it wanted me to be in it and it and it
was Satanism luciferianism sex parties
the whole nine yards I never got into
rituals but I was picked up by chicks
repeatedly trying to recruit me into
things in Dallas and a decade later in
Hollywood Austin's more new age you know
a lot of that here uh but that's almost
more a more creepy form of it so so I've
really you know I I never fell away and
said I'd announce God and God is a real
I'm an atheist but I mean I was in
points in my life I wasn't taking drugs
really but I was drinking and a lot of
women and yeah and on a power trip and
really prideful about how you know I was
and I'd say I got I'd say I was kind of
corrupt let's say
maybe 14 to about 20. uh and and then I
kind of rediscovered God and then the
Holy Spirit much more stronger than I
was saying when I was about 10 and and
then literally God started talking to me
and showing me things and like and I
would have dreams that came true and all
these things and I just now I get
stronger and stronger and stronger to
where you talk about spiritual warfare
we'll get into it at this point that's
all we I mean that is you have Christ
you have Jesus you have a faith in that
you are protected but then the Devil
comes after people that you love who
aren't in God that's why you've got to
get them into the Holy Spirit or the
devil is going to chew up your family in
front of you so that's why people better
understand this is more important than
guns in your gun cabinet or horrible
food or water right is getting your
heart and soul ready because believe me
folks without God you won't be able to
withstand Satan this is going to be
hardcore no flesh will be spared if God
doesn't intervene right and and I want
to bring something back up that you said
and I'll get to that in just a second
what you just said no flesh will be
spared unless God intervenes there's
some great quotes for us that that
really help us in Scripture that say
that unless the unless the Lord guards
the city the Watchman watches in vain
like it doesn't matter you can be as
prepared as you want to be but if God is
not watching over the city it really
doesn't matter right it's it's a bigger
picture than this but churches did get
away from this and I think maybe because
they started seeing people kind of
practice this escapism right so instead
of focusing on being productive here and
now right what am I supposed to do today
what am I supposed to do in the next
five years of my life if by chance the
Lord allows me to have those they
started looking kind of into the future
and they were so Heavenly minded that
they were no earthly good is what my
pastors would say every once in a while
but churches got away from preaching
about Revelation and Daniel and some
other topics that are very very
interesting and very important topics
because it basically gives you the
opportunity to point a scripture and go
God called that right in Ezekiel when it
talks about the dry bones and the nation
of Israel coming back like that's a
that's something that has to happen for
the Rapture to happen for the
tribulation to happen it talks about
them having a temple and having
sacrifices and then having the
Abomination that causes desolation set
up well if Israel isn't a country if
Israel doesn't have the Land There is no
Temple right there is no Temple right
now but it's impossible unless they're
there well until 1948 that was
impossible until modern television was
invented it was impossible for us to all
watch the two witnesses at the Wailing
Wall and it says that when those guys
are killed because they've tormented
people for this period of time just by
speaking the truth and withholding rain
to basically say guys you have to listen
let me get your attention no rain let me
get your attention listen to God loves
you he wants to save you they rejoice
and the entire world watches them die
and then they exchange gifts like it's
Christmas and then they're brought back
to life and it freaks everybody out
obviously if somebody was brought back
to life after three days laying on the
ground and we've been celebrating their
death it'd be a little weird I'd kind of
get freaked out too I get it I
understand but none of that
technologically was even possible and so
when churches don't get into this I
think they're doing a bit of a
disservice to their congregations
because it's almost think about what we
have now with kind of the cancel culture
right we're obviously both very familiar
with how that works in our society you
create a vacuum you start to create a
vacuum where people go okay well you're
not talking about this so I'm going to
go listen to 15 or 16 or 20 other people
over here talking about it and I may not
be grabbing good information right so
when you start canceling people in our
industry you start pushing them off into
the fringes you can't easily point out
the people who are absolutely out of
their minds and go you know what don't
listen to that guy he's never been right
before the the end of the world has
never come he's predicted it 17 times
and people go yeah you're right I can
see that I can see that this person's
not correct and not a reliable person to
judge or to listen to to kind of Judge
whether the world is actually coming to
an end or not and it actually does a
disservice to people so I think the
church has done a bad job with that let
me let me just lay a little bit of
groundwork here it's important that you
understand this it is not important that
you debate this to the death of other
believers people tend to get into these
things and go you know what I am a new
King James Bible person or a King James
Bible person and there are no other
translations that absolutely are the
word of God in your a heretic and you're
going to hell if you read the NIV right
they tend to kind of draw these lines
where we shouldn't we God judges the
heart cry folks about the Pharisees up
there praying in public he said no you
need to pray in private it's about you
and God and I just want to be clear with
people this isn't about even The
Messengers here the devil is 100 real
the operating system of the of the new
world order the U.N is luciferianism
they've got a Lucius Lucifer trust that
runs the prayer Chapel of in in New York
at the U.N I've had these people try to
recruit me and some of it wasn't just in
high school or then later when I was in
Hollywood some it it's happened since
then we're very well-known household
names said hey we want you to go to this
event in reykjavak or this event in
Switzerland and and it's new AG but
we're Lucifer's not really bad we're
gonna call in Lucifer to fix the
problems so I mean I start thinking
about how much of this week Bohemian
Grove I sneak in there I hear there's
this ritual they're doing a ritual to
the devil to do under all these
Canaanite names it's like Ghostbusters
or something but for real and I look
over and the old men are are are more
intense than when I was in Holy Roller
churches yeah you know because holy
world of churches great people are like
oh we love you Lord these people are
like ah I mean this is real all I'm
telling people is I don't know if you've
experienced stuff like this but I'm
telling you if you've seen the stuff
I've seen and I know God put me in those
places too see that yeah so I can now
witness this to people you would know
that God is real and I just keep
hammering that and and but what you said
is critical
there's a mix the whole Rapture thing
okay there's all this scary stuff coming
and the Bible's being fulfilled so far
because people can see it start to be
fulfilled in the 70s and 80s technology
so people go oh my gosh this really is
happening and then people go oh but
we're going to be raptured so let's just
go to sleep and stop looking at it yeah
and so it's a mix half the folks or
whatever percentage it is a certain
percentage are scared and don't really
want to be bothered with it because it
is awesome it is scary it is huge it's
it's it's it's Eternal it's a big
decision forever and the other ones are
just like Hey we're gonna get rapture
it's gonna be fine but if you really
look at the Bible I'm not going to
debate
post you know a mid or you know pre the
issue is right there we know there's a
big Awakening that of Christians later
that turn against the Antichrist and
then he starts killing everybody so we
know there's going to be a group that's
awake before a group that doesn't a huge
Awakening during it and and he correct
me if I'm wrong you say more than I do
and then the Antichrist is just
slaughtering people and once he goes
from a nice guy to mean guy and we're
going to have the biggest Revival ever
seen in the middle of this it's just so
any way you slice it folks it's real
it's happening and people better get
serious yeah absolutely so let me let me
just lay this out for you and we're not
going to debate it I may ask Alex kind
of where he falls down on this stuff I
really don't know it's very complex I
just know that God's real the devil it's
about to get it's about to get real
messy one way or the other right so look
a lot of people believe in what's called
a Rapture and if you're wondering what
that is that's a topic that's alluded to
in scripture I believe it's first
Thessalonians 4 that mentions being
caught up to heaven kind of in the
twinkling of an eye and there's a word
that's used there harpazzo right and
that's that's where they talk about this
Rapture like this instantaneous like
catching up to be with God and then at
some point there is a period of seven
years that's called either the time of
Jacob's trouble I think in Jeremiah or
um the tribulation right A lot of people
look at the tribulation they're like oh
it's a seven year period sort of the
entire tribulation is this seven year
period but really
the really scary thing Alex is that the
Antichrist when he comes to power is
accepted with open arms this person
doesn't come in as a conquering kind of
uh uh a dictator he could show up in red
pajamas right exactly right he doesn't
come in and say you know you have to
follow me people willingly do that and
before covid-19 hit most of you out
there right now probably thought like
there's no way the world would just kind
of jump in lockstep on something like
this and kind of give up their freedoms
willingly and shut down the entire world
economy and not ask really important
questions there's no way big Tech would
like completely censor genuine doctors
asking questions about this stuff
there's no way that would all happen
everybody's eyes got opened a little bit
on how quickly we fall apart how quickly
we are willing in times of trouble to
welcome in somebody who may not have our
best interest at heart who accept a
great delusion which the Bible says
if the the delusion was so strong it
could even deceive the elect what's the
exactly that's exactly what it is you
nailed it sometimes you just got to
believe in yourself Alex I mean it's I
mean I've read this 100 times but you're
trying to get the quote exactly right oh
no I so I always Loosely quote this
thing like I've got some scripture
written down just to make sure that I
get it accurate but if you hear us talk
about it it's a loose quote acts 17 11
was what I would always point you to
don't believe Alex don't believe Gerald
go and study scripture and see if it is
true right that is that is what Paul
that everybody should do that one of my
favorite teachers Chuck Missler always
talked about that so do that make sure
you do it right all right so this seven
years three and a half really good years
then things switch and three and a half
really bad years and that's what we talk
about that's the tribulation that three
and a half years so this seven year
period ends then there's a millennial
Kingdom which is a thousand year rule of
Christ on Earth New Jerusalem the whole
thing and then at the end of that
there's what they call the white Throne
judgment new heaven new Earth right
that's the basic layout there are other
things that happen in there and that I'm
not going to get into right now the
devil for a little while again he does
and I don't know why like at the end of
the Thousand Years so Satan is bound and
his his they're thrown into the pit for
a thousand years and he lets him out for
a little while and there's again there's
this additional battle that happens and
then there's free will it's like okay
you've had you've seen nothing but pure
goodness for a thousand years now let's
you want to be you know it's almost like
Adam and Eve all over again you get to
walk and talk with God essentially right
and now you have the opportunity again
to fall away and so there's this final
battle I don't know why I have no idea
why God does that but I understand that
God is good and just and I trust him a
lot more than I trust myself to figure
this out but that's true at the end of
it so some people believe that we're in
the Millennium right now and if so a lot
of pastors have said well if that's true
then the devil's chain is too long
because he's obviously on the market
well there's that teaching that
supposedly tied as sacked Rome I mean
sacked Jerusalem and that was the end of
the world then I mean it doesn't have
all the technology the mark of the beast
I I just really don't see that and it's
not understanding the all of that
discourse right that the other discourse
and I talked to my wife about this just
a little while ago by the way she loves
you she's a big fan God bless her
I married up
I was talking to her about that I heard
you said it on air you did you're a
handsome guy but she's quite delighted
she's fantastic
um in in Luke the all of that discourse
he's actually talking about he's talking
to Gentiles right so Luke is rent to uh
written to Gentiles so this is
Christians after the time of Christ
leading up to 70 A.D and he's talking
about this and he says don't waste any
time when you see the armies around
Jerusalem flee the city don't even go
back down and get your coat leave and
get out of the city that was the fall of
of Jerusalem in 70 80 when the city was
burned and Christ said that he said
before this generation passes not one
stone will be there 38 years later
that's pretty much exactly the same time
that they were wandering the desert as
well before they came into the promised
land so it's a very interesting quote
the generation had not passed but people
are like well wait a minute the Olivet
discourse in Luke sounds very similar to
the Olivet discourse in Matthew and so
they get confused Matthew is written to
Jews
Matthew's whole thing was writing to the
Jews and it was talking about two
different times Jesus at one time was
talking to the public during the day and
the other time he was kind of having
secret briefing meetings with his
disciples at night and so that's why
there's some confusion about whether
that actually already happened and we're
in a millennium or that there is no
Millennial Kingdom that's just really
some kind of really it's it's men
looking at the same mountain range from
different angles pretty much yeah you're
looking at the story and you're not
taking into context who he's writing to
and also like very simple things that
said and before these things this stuff
will happen and after these things these
things will happen it's like wait a
minute one says before and goes down
this entire list the other says after
and goes down this other way that's a
different conversation but we've kind of
looped those things together and it's
caused a lot of confusion all you really
need to know is there is a tribulation
there is a millennial Kingdom the Bible
definitely discusses it I don't
allegorize it I tend to take the Bible
more seriously and the more that I do
that the more that I see scripture being
well it says
that women will become men
over you I mean it's all it's like
insane like none of that ever went on
now it's like well this is being written
people are reading them this is crazy
that's never happened and then they're
like you guys are crazy come on really
guys becoming women that's just crazy
there's some effeminate men but let's
not go too far so one of the other
dividing lines is you know when in that
period of time the church is actually
taken out is it before that seven years
start is it at the midpoint so before
the bad time starts is it at the very
end because Christians don't get to be
exempt from the kind of I guess
persecution that they've experienced it
says the Beast will wage war against the
Saints and overcome them so if you want
to speak against the because to me it
says Christ comes back the Archangel
bounds Satan and then the dead in Christ
are raised and then and then and then
and that's the tribulation to me to me
it happens at the at the end of the
battle of Armageddon okay that seems to
be like a 10 year old could do that but
but so many Christians who believe in
Christ and love God are holding on to
that I don't want to run them away I
don't want to say you're going to hell I
don't want to preach at you hey if
that's what you believe that's fine but
then you're not gonna be ready for
what's already going down right so your
your responsibility is the same as a
Believer or somebody who's maybe
interested in what you know I guess the
Bible has to say about how the world is
going to go because looking around
you're probably thinking my goodness
things are not necessarily getting
better they're getting worse I tend to
come down on a pre-tribulation kind of
viewpoint right and so let me explain
why
um I don't if you understand what the
tribulation is about right if you
understand what those last three and a
half years are it is God's final chance
for the Jews the Jews that rejected
Christ he said I will return to my place
until they acknowledge their offense and
then I will come to them this is God
fulfilling Prophecy from Daniel it's the
70th week of Daniel that talks about
this very specifically and not only
predicts when Messiah will come but also
predicts this period of time that will
be unlike any other time worse than the
Holocaust right that's exactly what the
Bible is describing because if you look
at some of the numbers that it talks
about for how many people will be killed
it is far far far far worse but this is
the last chance of a loving father
saying I'm giving you one final
opportunity and I'm going to do some
things I'm going to tell you that I'm
going to do them so think of plagues of
Egypt right I'm just going to start
ratcheting up the pressure until finally
you let go and understand that I am God
and you are not so that's one of them
that's right God repeats the same it's
like over and over again so to the
Jewish mind pattern is prophecy so the
Bible isn't so much pattern developed
and kind of laid down the entire Book of
Joshua essentially is patterned for the
end times think about this in Joshua you
know when they're talking about the the
city of Jericho and the battle there and
they March around the walls and then
they scream and the walls fall down all
the kids know that from like Bible
stories when you're when you're a young
kid the part of it that we don't talk a
whole lot about is this two witness part
they send in two spies they don't get
any actionable Military Intelligence
because there is no battle plan that
includes going in and doing anything
it's just walking around the city you
don't have to have any intel for that
right the only thing that really happens
is that Rahab a harlot and her family
get saved she's Gentile so two witnesses
go in two witnesses at the Wailing Wall
Gentiles get saved Gentiles get saved it
it's a pattern that God is which then
does with Christ later exactly so it
just lays down this pattern throughout
scripture so the next thing that makes
me believe that if you look at
Revelation 3 it talks about the letters
to the seven churches and it actually
starts in chapter two but in chapter
three it comes to the Church of
Philadelphia a lot of people will make a
big deal about how these churches
actually represent kind of church ages
so to speak like an apostate church or a
Missionary church or an evangelical
church or a lukewarm church right so you
can look at all of these and kind of
study that that's a really interesting
thing to do the Church of Philadelphia
it actually says and I'll quote it here
in just a little bit it actually says
that if you hold on I will keep you I
will remove you from the time of trouble
that's very interesting so it's time
shadowing the pattern of a potential hey
it's possible that there's a Rapture
here's the important part I want to say
the important part I I hope you I hope
it's pretty and I I know right I am
praying that it's free as well trust me
if you've read Revelation I don't want
to be around for the last three and a
half years of the seven year I don't
want to be around for the first part of
it because there's going to be this guy
coming on the stage that everybody who's
a Christian if you're still around
you're going to know that's the
Antichrist things are about to get
really bad and it's not going to be a
fun time to be around like and he's
going to be healing people and miracles
and in the last more yeah yeah
politically is going to come to power
first and it's going to be just this
sweeping thing can you imagine somebody
from like Romania or pick you know pick
some country over in kind of Eastern
Europe can you imagine somebody coming
to power right now in the entire world
just bowing down to this person and
saying absolutely yes this person what
is it the Antichrist you study more than
I have what is what is he what's the
devil able to do to make people go into
this delusion and worship this guy so
it's it's a time of trouble right so
that's what we need historically we've
seen that with the rise of Hitler with
all of these different kind of dictators
depression a virus exactly something
like that so this time of trouble where
people are looking and willing to give
up freedom for security we've been
willing to do that throughout history
the Devil comes up with a solution yep
there's a person who comes in and has
the solution can bring World Peace can
unite people that you never thought
could unite and really what marks the
beginning of this is the signing of a
treaty with Israel and so Israel signs
the treaty with all of its neighbors to
have peace it's a seven year treaty and
that's where that seven year tribulation
that's area when Trump was getting that
done I know right when he moved the uh
the embassy yeah uh but that was that
was fantastic but there was no there was
no peace treaty with the neighbors who
no it was good what he was doing but I'm
just saying
what's happening no but it's part of it
right and so Russia plays kind of a key
role in this too in the battle of
Armageddon or that was it where were the
ones
it's Russia and its allies that
typically people believe that are the
the armies that come down and invade but
really The Seven Year treaty is what
kicks it off so if you're looking for
the start of this either you won't be
here and and maybe we were correct in
thinking that the church would be pulled
out or you'll see a treaty signed and
you'll be here but only for the good
part or you'll be here for all of it
either way doesn't change what you do
none of that matters this isn't
something that you debate a lot of times
you know you talk about different
doctrines and people are like I don't
know if you have to be baptized to be
saved and I go you know what I don't
know either thief on the cross wasn't
baptized you know what I do know Christ
said to get baptized that's all I need
to know I don't know what it does I'm
going to do commands
well I mean but here's
to know if that's salvific right if it's
going to be a part of the Salvation plan
I don't know I just know what Christ
said to do here he says to be ready you
can't know the hour in the day but you
can know the season Jesus actually holds
people responsible and accountable for
not knowing the time it is coming that's
what he was crying exactly you don't
know the exact time but you know the
season exactly right and so the Book of
Revelation is actually God the Father
revealing the plan to God the son Jesus
telling John on the Isle of Patmos so
many people don't catch that in the
first couple of verses this is the
Revelation to Jesus
from God it says that right at the start
at the very start and we'd read right
over and go okay well this is just the
Revelation to John No John is there is a
witness to record now he has a problem
because he's seeing stuff that he has no
idea how to describe but at the same
time he's doing his best when he says
that you've got something that spews
sulfur out of its mouth and it's got the
power to sting you in its tail okay
what does that sound like modern times
right spewing sulfur out of its mouth
okay people have conjectured maybe
that's a tank okay that sounds right
soldiers behind it could be the tail
because they have weapons and they can
sting for the tail okay if you're John
and you have you know horses and Buggies
it's hard to describe these kinds of
things in a way that will make sense and
so John had a problem he had to describe
these things in a way that hopefully
people would be able to understand but
again the point isn't was he talking
about tanks that's really irrelevant the
point is there's a time of trouble the
likes of which the world has never known
World War One people thought was the end
of the world they actually thought it
was called the war to end all wars
exactly except it was the war to start
another War right it was insane and
people thought oh my gosh with World War
II this really does have to be the end
it is going to get way worse than that
that's what scripture think about world
at least 25 million Russians 22 million
Germans died and a lot of 600 000
Americans a million you know I mean it
was but the point was we were we were on
the tail end of it I mean the Russians
and Germans we waited as long as we
possibly could because trench warfare
didn't sound like it was going anywhere
and it didn't we were smart and said we
put our troops that's where the Army Air
corps was so big and big big machines
dropping bombs yeah it seemed smarter it
was insane but people thought the world
was going to end and people thought that
the Antichrist should be on the stage
and ready to go but it's just going to
get worse and that's not to scare you
but the Bible even says there are many
Antichrist there's models of it well
there has to be because Satan doesn't
know when the end is going to come
anyway so he has to be prepared pretty
much in everything he's not omnipresent
no he has to be prepared pretty much in
every generation to have an antichrist
and that's this is conjecture so I'll be
hold this Loosely but theoretically that
means that Hitler could have been
Antichrist if the timing was right
exactly the spirit was ready to do it
right I'm not saying yeah but this was
the Antichrist but but I'm with you
let's go talk about we talk about
Patrick Bateman or whatever he just
wrecked to me in my holy you know the
spirit mean I look at Newsom and I go
that's the devil I mean my my gut just
goes whoa not just his actions there's
people there there's real evil there
yeah and I'm not saying he's the devil
but he's probably like I mean there's
whatever's running him was like I mean
like tenant to Satan yeah exactly we'll
get into a little bit about spiritual
warfare but I think that is 100 spot on
that there are people that are
influenced very very very heavily by
evil and scripture talks a lot about
that so speaking of scripture I just
want to we've mentioned the Book of
Daniel I just want to read a real quick
quote here and uh we'll throw it up on
the on the screen in post we don't have
it right now so we won't be able to see
it Alex but I'll read it to you sure So
Daniel 9 24 this so this is the 70 weeks
of Daniel so 70 weeks are decreed about
your people in your Holy City to finish
the transgression to put it into sin and
to atone for iniquity to bring in
Everlasting righteousness and seal both
the vision and profit and to anoint the
most holy place okay that's does that
sound like that has happened has sin
been put to an end no okay so 70 weeks
so we are not at the end of that 70-week
period yet or some of those things would
have happened some of those things might
be able to happen in the first 69 and
then there's a pause and then there's a
70th week of Daniel which is what it
gets into know therefore and understand
and this is this is the prediction to
the day of when Jesus would come and
present himself as Messiah that so many
people Miss know therefore and
understand that from the going out of
the word to restore and rebuild
Jerusalem to coming of the anointed one
a prince versus Messiah there shall be
seven weeks then from Ben for 62 weeks
it shall be built again with squares and
moat but in a troubled time and so it's
talking about when they're building the
city when they're rebuilding Jerusalem
you're actually going to have to build
with one hand and have a sword in the
other hand and I believe they talk about
that a little bit in Nehemiah right so
artist Xerxes longymonis actually gives
the decree for them to go and rebuild
the city and they do so that's the
beginning of the clock and there's some
really cool studies again Chuck Missler
does a great study on this to kind of go
okay here's the day because we have good
records on when that was now how long is
this weeks of years kind of period that
they talk about and he'll go into a
study on that we're not going to get
into that now those that come down and
ride around now no it's talking about
when Christ would come the first time oh
yeah so there's something like the Old
Testament precursors the same way right
so this is Daniel saying look Messiah is
going to come at some point
gonna get some aguay hair you out I'll
ratch you out as she's coming in very uh
secretly my apologies so Messiah is is
prophesied is coming here right and so
the Jews are looking for the coming of
aside because he's going to deliver them
and everything's going to be great and
they're not going to be overtaken by
anybody they're not going to be having
all the problems that they are right now
especially when Jesus actually does come
they're being ruled by terrible people
with the Romans and they they really
were looking for their deliverer to come
and it's really interesting I was
talking to my wife earlier about this
today we a lot of times don't understand
what Jesus is doing because he'll heal
somebody and he'll say don't say
anything don't say who did it don't
don't do anything with this keep quiet
be secret like he does that over and
over and over again when his mom comes
to him at the wedding of Cana one of my
favorite Miracles because I'm a wine guy
and says I'm gonna I want you to take
care of this problem woman my time has
not yet come like I'm not supposed to do
some of these things yeah it's not yet
so Jesus constantly pushes back on this
and he's holding back on his power and
then there's one time where he demands
it and commands it and that's on the
triumphal entry on the day that Jesus
looks out over the city and weeps over
Jerusalem and said if you had only known
the time of your deliverance basically
holding them accountable for
understanding The Book of Daniel and
saying you didn't know that I was coming
and this is not going to go well I wish
that wasn't the case and how can I not
deny it now when Jesus came and warned
him and everything he said now came true
absolutely I mean it's ridiculous it is
and he actually said some people came up
to him some of the leaders the spiritual
leaders and said make sure tell your
people not to do what they're doing
right now because they're saying Hosanna
Hosanna hosanna in the highest blessed
is he who comes in the name of the Lord
tell them not to do that and Jesus looks
at them and says look if they don't do
it the rocks will cry out and do it
creation will declare who I am because
today's the day and you should have been
ready for that right so Jesus said when
he wrote it on the donkey yeah
I know they get mad about this we love
them to death how and a lot of them are
coming to Christ how can they get mad
when the Messiah told them and then it
all came true I mean like God knew this
as well God knew that they would miss
this God you mentioned it earlier when
people were I think you were talking
about them praying in public and making
these eloquent prayers and then you've
got this sinner over there that says
have mercy on me God I am a sinner
that's the heart that he wants not
somebody praying in public for public
recognition King David really was sorry
and prayed in private absolutely well he
prayed in private but he he wasn't
making a big show of things if he did
something in public like he danced
before God without his tunic on like he
had pants on but probably no shirt he
danced before God there was nothing
wrong with that because it was genuine
what what God had a problem with what
Jesus got in in human form had a problem
with was fake belief fake sincerity fake
piety people who said one thing did
another thing and then actually lorded
it over kind of the lady that the people
right and said hey you guys have to do
all of these things because of God and I
am God's Minister but I'm I'm cheating
I'm doing all these things that I
shouldn't be doing uh but don't worry
about that that's why I call them
whitewash tombs well Gerald if you if
you had a national which you have with
with either HTM and Crowder if you had a
national TV show preached every week I'd
tune in you're good you're smart man
well thank you very much I appreciate it
but no I would that's what we're doing
right now I guess I'm kind of chicken
the Holy Spirit to say something because
you know I mean chicken of the egg we
are talking to Millions right now so
well yeah absolutely no and so and then
it goes on and talks about um a covenant
that is made for one week and this is
where the week kind of weeks of years
thing comes in
um in in in Judaism like there's you can
have a week of years right so it's it's
kind of something that's foreign to us
we say a week we mean seven days you can
actually have that mean seven years
right so it's just kind of a figure of
speech and so Daniel kind of gives that
to us in verse 27 to make a strong
Covenant with many for one week and for
half of the week so the first half so
that you don't miss it by the way the
Book of Revelation says it three
different ways it says 300 and I can't
remember the number of days it's like
1200 and something days three and a half
years and it gives you the months it
does months weeks years multiple times
to make sure that you understand to take
three and a half year period it's 360
day years though which is very
interesting to me somebody can do some
research on that
I think there's a really interesting
book out there but I think called When
Worlds Collide that talks about
potentially how the calendar can change
around a little bit but that's again
that's but what do we say to the average
person who doesn't believe in God but
then really worships the system what are
they going to do as this world
government comes in that surveils you
with AI and you've got to submit and
follow everything it tells you or it
takes your right to have a job or eat or
live or traveling basically kills you I
mean that is you've got to worship the
Beast to get the mark of the beast and
so what do you think what is we know the
devil is the Antichrist but what is the
Beast system Gerald Near View and then
what is it we have to do to get this
Mark because like you said you don't get
it by accident so how do you refuse it
you so you'll know that the good thing
is that you will know nobody will ever
accidentally take the mark of the beast
and that was a question that a lot of
people had like look with RFID tags with
uh I don't know pull out your phone like
if you live in China basically you take
out your phone and it scans it and
that's how you buy stuff that's how you
you see if you're qualified to get on an
airplane or train or get a car loan
maybe go to college if your ESG score
essentially is social I know Excel
without a social credit score but
nonetheless I mean it's all kind of one
thing I think we've talked about the ESG
stuff as well all of that is the same
thing so people thought oh am I
accidentally doing that people thought
barcodes because the dividers were sixes
and it said 666. I'm like look it's not
barcodes just because you go to the
store and you buy some cheese doesn't
mean that you've taken the mark of the
beast it will be a bowing down to a
world system think of the story of
Nebuchadnezzar and Shadrach Meshach and
Abednego there was a big statue over
there they bowed down before it and
worshiped it worshiped it multiple times
a day and they stood up and said we're
not going to do it right that's what
you'll have the opportunity to do it
won't happen by accident but the way the
mechanisms for that to be carried out
are being put in place right now and
that's what's incredible you read
Revelation and you're like how do they
do it you worship it you got to submit
and then you get the Mark it's not like
you just agree to take kid you have to
worship it and do whatever it says they
have all these patents where you're
watched by Ai and Lifetime and you
follow its orders completely or it's
taken away from you so you become a
robot and turn your free will over and
become an extension of antichrist right
I mean and so God's like yeah you've cut
yourself off when I made you and gave
you all this creativity and all this
freedom and free will if you merge with
this basically marry the devil and put
the ring on your finger of this Mark
then then that's it you're done yeah
when they talk about the once you take
the mark of the beast you're right you
can't come back from that there is no
coming back and so if I I believe in a
Rapture that takes Christians out which
leaves a pretty terrible World in my
mind just back up for a second though
but that means
you've got the people on the cross and
one of them believe the other does that
guy you'll be with me in Paradise but
think about it what is it you got to do
that's so bad in the process that to get
that Mark to get that sign you've done
you've done the ultimate Center you've
done something so bad God says it's not
just that you took it it's like to get
that marks to me is what did it yeah so
this is really this is the final chance
I think it's just the final straw kind
of thing like this is you declaring
sides you've picked your side kind of at
the last put the enemy uniform on
exactly right and right now we have
Grace we have the covering of Christ and
and praise God for it because there are
days where and it's gonna be rough you
may like maybe your children have sided
with Antichrist God forbid I mean
there's gonna be a moment where you're
like my family did it I'm taking it fine
about it on well then you won't it's
just no you've got to say sorry I mean
it absolutely you you have to and you're
it will cost you your life like you
won't be able to buy or sell means you
can't eat like maybe people will set up
co-ops there's a really cool series of
books called Left Behind by Tim lahay
and Jerry Jenkins that I read when I was
in high school I started reading them
and they came out over I guess the
course of maybe 10 or 15 years they
wrote a ton of them really really
interesting stuff but it describes okay
well you know think of the Practical
things that could happen somebody can
set up a co-op and have Believers around
the world there's some kind of a system
where they're trying to kind of help
people be fed and help people get moved
out of cities that are I guess locking
down and by the way the U.N and and the
Rockefeller Foundation 10 years ago put
out plannedopolis and they said we're
gonna put the people that won't take our
chips and accept our system in these
ghettos yeah and it said they're going
to have like it describes that well so
even the enemy sees the same perspective
it's weird yeah absolutely and and so
many people think that it's impossible
for that system I want to go back to
this because this really is the test
case
this is absolutely the test case so
we've talked about how covid-19 mirrored
how maybe the world government could
take over because we need it because
it's so bad it's going to kill everybody
it's not gonna kill everybody right it's
so bad it's going to kill everybody that
everybody has to do this
take it one step further
it's not just that the situation is dire
and that we need to take these drastic
economic measures and freedom kind of
restricting measures it's that people
who speak out against it
are worthy of death
how many celebrities did we see tweeting
Fu if you don't have the vaccine and you
come through your freedom yeah exactly
Arnold Schwarzenegger if you don't have
the vaccine and you come to the hospital
you should die and somebody else should
be taken care of they weren't
resuscitating people with heart attacks
in the United States because the
hospital was too full and it wasn't
exactly none of these hospitals were too
full we've talked about this like that
is the kind of mentality people will
have you are now an enemy not just an
enemy ideologically not just somebody
that I need to make sure doesn't run for
office and win but somebody who should
not have a job a way to provide for
their family a place to live or even
that's why China's the model so from
from your research the models you've
done a better job than I have I always
remember in in Sunday school and stuff
they're going to be Guillotines chop a
Christian's heads off I mean what does
the bible actually say about that versus
what people made up 100 true so if you
don't have the mark of the beast if you
refuse to worship the punishment of
choice is separating you from your head
which is typically fatal
that's a lot better than going to hell
supposed to be a joke
it's so it's so serious a lot of people
think okay well what other world
religion right now because it will come
in under a world religion don't don't be
fooled don't think that they're gonna
say God is not real that's not what
they're going to say they're going to
say yes God is real but God is this
right they'll say you can still be
Christian but you're not real you must
accept every other religion we have to
accept all of these other things what
religion right now kills apostates by
cutting off their heads Islam Islam
absolutely what regions are we talking
about when we talk about some of the
places that this all is going to happen
Middle East Middle East do you think
it's any surprise that that probably
plays a prominent role I have no idea
and Islam didn't exist for 400 years
after
the Revelation I was I think Islam came
around in what the 600s 500 600 years
500 600 yeah something like that this
was this was something this guy was I
didn't I didn't even plan on getting
Islam but there's this topic that I've
studied a lot this guy was rejected by
the Jews he wanted to be Jewish but he
was rejected he was rejected by
Christians as well
and then he kind of dabbled in some
Zoroastrianism yeah exactly or they're
at the crossroads of of the of the of
the East-West trade he watched all this
absolutely and he kind of based
everything off of that what's really
interesting maybe we can do another one
on this so when we talk about
eschatology there are players in this
like there's the Beast there is the
Antichrist and and so you've got kind of
the false prophet you've got all these
kind of characters at play in
Christianity and we go okay those are
the bad guys the Messiah coming back so
Jesus coming back that's the good guy if
you study Islamic eschatology they have
the same cast of characters except the
roles are reversed
all of the bad guys for them are the
good guys and our good guy actually
becomes a prophet for them Jesus is a
prophet that actually comes and allows
Muhammad to take Center Stage it is
absolutely mind-blowing when you dive
into it so like they believe this stuff
too there's an eschatology to their game
as well there's an end times like the
12th Imam one of my favorite authors uh
Josie Rosenberg they believe starting
nuclear war brings exactly it has to be
so bad now think about that
if they think to bring back their kind
of world order that they want their
their their Messiah essentially they
have to make the world so bad I just
described to you a scenario where the
world is going to get so bad that
somebody coming to power it's going to
be very easy for us to hand over our
freedom and our Liberty because they'll
make the world better and we need
somebody to do that these things line up
they think that they have to do that we
don't we just know that it will happen
that's the message
sit there and come out with the amazing
stuff that's in the the Torah and then
they're waiting for it and then when it
finally comes it changes the whole world
and empowers all these societies nope
nothing against the Renaissance and
everything we have and they just go nope
we're not accepting that so here's why
here's why the Jews missed it so in the
book of Isaiah there are some prophecies
that talk about Jesus right so there's
some very clearly Messianic prophecies
that they Overlook Israel was expecting
a conquering King
because in Scripture it says that the
Messiah will be a conquering King that
seems reasonable right what they didn't
understand is that they missed that he
would first be a suffering servant that
there are two times the Messiah comes
they were looking for the second time he
came the first time and did this and
Jesus even quoted this and and I'll
butcher the quote if I do it but it's
when he stands up and the scroll is unre
unraveled and he reads kind of a thing
from Isaiah and he stops and where he
stopped was actually a point where it's
I think it's talking about setting
captives free I think don't quote me on
this I could be just getting this a
slight bit off and he stops kind of at a
comma so to speak the comma didn't exist
we inserted that but he stopped right
there and right after that it's
referring to the second time when it's
talking about judgment and destruction
and thank God he stopped because if he
had come back the first time with
condemnation for Sinners people who had
completely rejected God none of us would
have had a chance we would have been
born in the first place but people would
not even had a chance but he stopped
right there and the Jews missed it
because they saw present conditions suck
Rome occupies us we don't even think and
how are you going to get a messiah that
fixes everything if everybody doesn't go
under it yeah I mean it's like the
Messiah comes everybody's got to follow
it everybody has to and so that's why
they missed it and so when it's hard for
them to come back to it but here's one
of the other things that I'll tell you
kind of kind of a wrapping up Point as
to why this all matters just a little
bit more one of the things that people
get I guess confused about is all of the
language of Revelation well Revelation
one through three is very clear very
easy to understand it's letters to
churches it's some admonitions it's
actually really interesting The Book of
Revelation is the only book in the Bible
with the audacity to say as Chuck
Missler would say read me I'm special
because it basically promises a blessing
to those who read and understand it's
the only book of the Bible that does
that so it's a very important thing to
remember read that book there's a
blessing to people who read that book
first three chapters pretty easy you get
to chapter four The Language changes
all of a sudden you start to hear things
that are very Jewish
very very Jewish they start to tell
stories that you don't really understand
and you're like oh my gosh I don't
really understand what they're talking
about with with the moon and the stars
and the Sun and the lady in this piece
and that's really strange if you
understand your Old Testament that gets
very clear very quickly that is why the
church has messed up so much on the Book
of Revelation because the church doesn't
spend a lot of time teaching you the Old
Testament and giving you a verse by
verse by verse understanding of what
Christ said he came to fulfill the Old
Testament not to override it exactly
he's like I came to fulfill all of the
law not to get rid of it every single
thing that has been said in scripture
will be fulfilled but all of it is
written of Christ the Writ the things
that were written a four time were for
your benefit the Old Testament is very
important if you understand your Old
Testament you will understand the Book
of Revelation much much better and you
won't fall victim I think you have to
know the Old Testament to know that you
do but most people think about this when
you're a Christian I mean growing up in
the 90s
I was a Christian I was in church and I
read mostly the New Testament I really
wasn't studying the Old Testament until
I got into my 20s and went to Ministry
school and I was like I just can't get
enough of this like this is explaining
so much because we're already starting
to make sense before it's all the same
stuff we did again right exactly it's
just repeating the prophecy is pattern
thing like there are some things that
will just blow your mind in scripture
where you're like I had no idea that
when when Moses lifted up a snake on a
brass snake and people looked upon it
they were healed of the afflictions and
Christ refers to that and says just like
when Moses lifted up the serpent in the
desert the son of man will be lifted up
and he who looks upon me will be healed
it was a pattern that he was laying down
in scripture but most people miss that
because they never read the first story
in the first the pattern of the king
because it connects it all together
energetically and you see the patterns
being fulfilled right God using patterns
to kind of set prophecy and those things
being fulfilled so it's very important
to understand the Old Testament so I'd
highly encourage you to do that if you
want to study the Book of Revelation
there's a lot of great people out there
that you can look at I highly recommend
Chuck Missler just because I think he's
the right kind of teacher he's humble
he'll talk to you about stuff that's
interesting but he'll say it's
conjecture not to hold on to that too
tightly but he'll also tell you verse by
verse by verse and Link you back to the
Old Testament every single time if
there's one thing about what Chuck
Missler did he died in 2018 but he was
just a phenomenal teacher he would take
I think 30 hours to go through the Book
of Revelation and kind of walk you
through all of this because he's going
back to the Old Testament so much to
kind of show you okay this is what it's
talking about here's what this is
talking about what's incredible is
what I'm seeing the Great Awakening
happening the third great Christian
Awakening that we've had in the last 300
years is it is it's not that the church
is even teaching this when it should be
because this is the reality people are
hungry for it it's that people are out
in the world and saying yeah the
Satanism and the occultism and the devil
worship and the the destruction and the
attack on God the attack on family I
mean it really is satanic and so
if people think it's bad now it's gonna
get crazier and crazier and crazier yeah
and so that's why people I think really
seem to understand that we're on a
planet in space we're giving free will
God really did make us there really is
this outside force you know there's all
the new agers say it's space aliens or
whatever what is the devil it's an
interdimensional creature stranded here
with an army that wants to control us
well lies wouldn't be because we're made
in the image of God and look what we
imagine what we're able to build now the
we're like babies still oh yeah the
technology the things we've done is
nothing because we are actually more
advanced than God's angels and then this
is my layperson
but I mean we are made in the image of
God we have eternal spirits and God made
other things before and decided to make
us later and these things are jealous of
us and want to kill us well I want to
get rid of us I mean it's really the
Demonic forces yeah absolutely you
should talk about we'll talk about
spiritual warfare in one second here I
think we'll we'll make that into another
episode because I think that'll be
really interesting I wish you a lot of
episodes I want to do them well you know
I think we'll do that in a minute
because that's really important but look
to Alex's Point like that we're held
responsible as a Believer as a number
whoever it is it doesn't matter you're
held responsible for the information
that you have access to and right now
you have access to God saying hey you
won't know the day and the hour that's
fine don't worry about that know the
season
we're in the season whether that season
is going to take a long time to fulfill
I'm not the guy saying hey in two years
and five years and ten years I'm just
saying that you need to be prepared
because that's what God tells you to do
not because I am saying that not because
I'm trying to sell you some emergency
supply kit or make you a great prepper
I'm just saying it is good for you to be
ready it's also good for you to know the
end of the story we win
we overcome this through Christ thank
God literally because the world is a
very terrible place it's very sad when
you have movies coming up about human
trafficking and that's just one fraction
of the debauchery that is on this planet
the things that we do to each other make
God cry and it all comes to an end and
he wipes away every single tear from
every single eye and you don't have to
worry about that anymore evil is finally
dealt with Injustice and I think that's
something really important to say here
and I know we're taping this today so
when you put it in post maybe you can
add AOC and Al Gore and Beto saying the
world ends in 2030. they mean they're
artificially collapsing things to
consolidate power and depopulate but but
but really it's you've all know a Harari
and Bill Gates of them saying the future
is not Human by 2047 there'll be no
humans you must merge the machines or
we'll get rid of you they're the ones
saying it's the end of the world they
are they are literally fulfilling
prophecy I remember my grandfather would
say the devil can't help it he must
follow God's plan he will fulfill the
prophecy and that's the thing is they
think we're the ones saying into the
world no we're trying to keep the gas
pipelines going we're trying to keep the
nitrogen going we're trying to keep the
farming going we're trying to stop Wars
stabilize the third world we're not like
oh we want the end of the world let's
drink Kool-Aid it's the left and the
globalists that are fulfilling it to
bring in the crisis and then they can
stop the crisis because they're running
it with their Antichrist well in our
next episode of this we're actually
going to dive into that because that's
where Spiritual Warfare comes in if you
think that it's just maybe some demonic
possession things where somebody's head
spins around and they vomit green stuff
at you think again it gets a little
deeper than that thank you very much for
being with us that is Gerald apologizes
apologetics with Alex Jones great being
with you
Gerald apologizes apologetics
mean that
I told you it was going to be a very
interesting conversation Alex Jones for
an hour on the end times but look we
actually Dove a little bit deeper into
spiritual warfare that portion is going
to be released on mug Club so if you are
not a member make sure you join the
network today 89 annually and you're
going to gain access to The Hodgetwins
uncensored Nick depalo show Brian
Collins weekly show Mr guns and gear and
of course the white whale himself Alex
Jones if you want to see more of these
type shows the apologetic shows please
leave us a comment and join up now join
us in the fight guys we will see you
very soon